welcome sorry well I kept to this video
playing a guy from from France and not
sure how to pronounce that its own what
that's also um in German nibble it's in
German that this is the German word word
for [ __ ] so on maybe this is nibble it's
also a French word ok we have done we M
we have the the sloth defense here and
tae force the main move but after that
we get the some peace sacrifice we
should be for which I really don't know
hmm ok maybe that takes e4
I'd like to avoid that I don't want to
want this heavy theoretical discussion
maybe Bishop g5 94 is playing a c5
problem and I cannot take on c5 because
I way I can I actually can well now that
I spent far too much time here trying to
avoid the main line okay this is
sometimes a real problem if you player
all openings like I do here look at once
in a while you really get involved in oh
and a theoretical line that playing over
the board without ya without being able
to rely on unknown knowledge this is a
problem sometimes okay but this looks
looks quite decent I wonder if not be
five is an idea night c7 being a threat
and 96 being a threat yeah i lost the
lost castling rights but this is
probably not so important here what the
heck if the sir was a message from a new
printer that I just bought today okay um
okay well i can go 96 here and win this
pawn not sure if it is a good idea ya
know he might play long castles
check let's let's do that hmm okay I
expected him to take to be honest to
take first okay okay let's let's just
take that the night on b7 is also
covering d8 for the mode the main point
of the set up with f3 and divorce if
black is not managing to to solve this
this thing with the text sacrifice only
for the the big early the big point is
that I'm shutting out the logistics
Bishop and then Bishop f4 is played too
I could have played 95 195 attacking the
the night on a six and 96 this would
have been much stronger you that's a
Miss well maybe maybe he's not he's not
preventing it may be young he's now he
is preventing it now 95 was was just
winning flat however it may be is still
winning 95 night c5 isn't really a great
great line okay let's let's do that
I think he needs to play 95 where where
else and after that I can take G
sequence check and play Bishop d6 just
exchanging exchanging yeah well maybe
that's not so great actually oh he's
playing for a counter-attack interesting
ok bill Bishop e3 years am I still a
good move yeah well I'll take it I mean
this was hanging all along strange that
he didn't react elaborate resign yeah
black was was in some trouble anyway but
yeah Bishop f4 really I mean it's not
it's not bad but 95 I think just wins
yeah this just rinsed the game I'm
attacking the knight and threatening
knight c6 to win the bishop I mean if
flack must play it be eight and this is
just just lost I it's even it's even
technically lost yeah this is this is
very good whereas this Bishop going I
guess know where you can play a five if
he goes here i can take check win the
peace so um yeah II five but this is
this is a disaster it's a pawn and this
is a dead piece on g6 as mentioned f3
year for this pawn chain ism is designed
to keep this this Bishop out of play and
he never really really managed I'm not
sure I'm i don't really know this
opening too well but i'm not sure that
Bishop c5 is even even
rightmove maybe it is but this this this
type of plan can be interesting at the
moment of threatening 96 0 9 a-6 here
certainly not on but maybe it like our
maybe black and castle first i play rook
d8 quickly something like that this
might might be possible after after this
it's already a bit tricky I mean what
what what does blake playing so not not
stop obvious at all the computer wants
to play king this happened or just
really wow really ugly yeah but night a6
probably fled out losers check I'm just
I'm just taking that and black has no
compensation it looks a bit a bit
strange because I'm having the king on
d1 and I'm not completely developed but
black's pieces are just on salad city
positions they are out out and not on
the initial squares but they do they do
nothing especially the a6 night is just
a liability and i have from easy plane
yeah the cern didn't really work out
well for black thus opening alright
thanks for watching